in my opinion this is officially the
movie where the rock became Dwayne
Johnson and you had it in your pal
I knew it snitch tells the tale of a
father played by Dwayne Johnson whose
son is imprisoned because he decides to
accept a package that he knows has drugs
in it he didn't learns that his friend
that sent the drugs was actually setting
him up he is now in jail because he was
caught with these drugs
so obviously Johnson is running around
trying to help his son trying to figure
out how he can help him reduce this
absurdly long sentence that he's been
given for jail for just this one little
mistake and the only way that Dwayne
Johnson can get him out of jail is if he
helps Susan Sarandon and Barry Pepper
wearing the goatee of life let me just
say that Wow incriminates and arrest a
drug dealer that his son's sentence will
be reduced significantly going into this
movie I wasn't expecting anything great
I didn't really have high hopes for the
movie and I gotta say I'm really
surprised by this movie it was actually
pretty good and I was really invested in
the story and that's one of the most
important things I can take away from
any type of movie as I can say you know
what I actually legitimately wanted to
know what was gonna happen during this
movie I wanted to see it play out I
wanted to know the direction the
characters were gonna go I wanted to see
how they were gonna get there and Dwayne
Johnson this is definitely the best
performance I've ever seen from him for
sure he actually gives a legitimately
great performance in this movie for his
character I was very impressed he's not
an action hero at all on this movie so
don't go to this movie expecting to see
the rock beat up a bunch of people or
even really do anything action-oriented
this is definitely a drama it was really
fun to see this character who starts out
in the movie very clean he's a good guy
as a construction business and then all
of a sudden he's facing this ultimatum
he has to figure out a way to go into
this seedy underworld to try to figure
out how these people work so that he can
help when these people be arrested
because he's an informant but to see his
character have to go through those hoops
to try to get to a more evil or darker
place in his life was actually pretty
interesting like I was actually seeing
they're going like this is this is a
good movie I'm really surprised this is
this is not a bad movie at all movie
isn't without its problems there's an
extra character in the movie that
Johnson has to get to know because this
guy can help him get into that world
he's kind of like a bridge into this
drug world that he's
trying to infiltrate this guy's story
while important to the movie kind of
took away from it at times
I was really focused on Johnson's story
I was just like what's this guy gonna do
I want to know what he's gonna do and
oftentimes the film with sidetrack to
this other character who was very
important to the story but his character
in his life was not as interesting for
me and so for that reason certain parts
of this movie did drag a little bit the
direction is not like anything
spectacular but one of the things I
liked about it was that it didn't get in
the way it's really easy with a movie
like this to be like hey I'm gonna show
off how good of a director I am and get
all these amazing fancy shots to make
everything like really dramatic and
in-your-face and everything but he
pulled back a lot I thought and I was
impressed with him as a director for
this movie because you tell that he was
able to get his actors into a good place
and actually provide some pretty good
dramatic scenes too that didn't feel
forced and that's very important when
you're working with material like this
it actually seemed like okay I believe
that that guy is actually a drug dealer
right now and that's a credit to the
performers in this movie to the movie
just had a very realistic vibe
especially for a pg-13 movie I was
impressed with it so I actually found
snitch to be a pretty good movie but
don't go to this movie and expect a
whole bunch of action sequences because
that's not this kind of movie at all and
despite the fact that some aspects of
the story were not as interesting as
others
I was always engaged in the general flow
of the movie and that is definitely
something to say because I really didn't
expect much out of this movie I'm gonna
give snitch a B I definitely suggest
seeing it if you are fan of Dwayne
Johnson or if him as a wrestler I
shouldn't really be surprised that he's
becoming a pretty good actor because
most wrestlers are actors but I did see
the movie the wrestler so I do have
respect for what they do
as always guys thanks a lot for watching
and if you like this and you can click
right here and get stuck mine eyes